تعهد الرئيس الروسي لديمير بوتين بتحقيق
جميع اهداف بلاده في اوكرانيا وقال ان كل
صراعات تنتهي بالدبلوماسيه متهما واشنطن
بالسعي لاطاله امد الحرب وغداه زياره قام
بها الرئيس الاوكراني الى الولايات
المتحده تخللها لاعلى نوعا مساعدات عسكريه
لاوكرانيا تتضمن منظومه صواريخ باتريات
اعتبر بوتين ان المنظومه قديمه واقل كفاءه
من المنظومه الروسيه اس 300 متعهدا
بتدميرها
نشطت صيني سالتهم للتوا عن ما اذا كان من
الممكن الحديث عن مشاركه اكبر للولايات
المتحده في الصراع باوكرانيا اقترح ان
ننظر الى هذا الامر بصوره اشمل واعمق لان
الولايات المتحده تمارس هذا الامر منذ مده
طويله وفيما يحدث في فضاء ما بعد الاتحاد
السوفياتي هناك مؤسسات كامله عملت على ما
يحدث في اوكرانيا اما بالنسبه الى صواريخ
باتريوت هذا نظام قديم نوعا ما فهو لا
يعمل مثل 300 وسيكون هناك دائما لها
الامداد الموعود بانظمه الدفاع الجوي
الامريكيه
اولئك الذين يفعلون ذلك يفعلون ذلك عبثا
انه فقط يطيل امد الصراع هذا كل شيء